[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh nick saban the alabama head coach uh
joining us on the program
uh coach did you have your uh little
debbie's cakes today
oh yeah
is that uh is that some some things
never change
[Laughter]
what if they're not there how's your day
go after that
well i got probably the two of the
largest cookie jars you've ever seen in
your life
full of them and when they get half full
i sort of go into panic mode
and some kind of way they get filled
back up
is it somebody's job to fill up your
cookie jar that's their that's their
main job
that's their job yeah you know
that's one of the reasons i'm afraid to
retire you know i said it could be
anybody there to fill up my cookie jar
[Laughter]
uh i'm sure that there's some coaches
around the sec that would gladly
uh you know fill up your cookie jar if
you decided to leave
yeah maybe
do you feel out of a bracket for march
madness you ever done that before
yeah really i do it every year
we have we do we do a family um
like everybody in the family both sides
of the family
you know my daughter her husband his
family you know everybody
and um you know i really don't want to
sound you know facetious or anything but
i had baylor winning it all
which kind of made me the winner
[Laughter]
i didn't know you followed college
basketball well i don't that's what the
hard thing about picking the breaks is
because i i picked baylor and i hadn't
seen them or gonzalez either one play
all year right
you know i kind of just rely on you know
every now and then i see some replays on
you know espn or something or hear
people talk about them
so it's uh yeah i really don't have much
time to watch it so it's
uh kind of hit or miss you know
i didn't start out very well the last
four in you know those games
yeah that ucla was in i was over four
i didn't pick one of them that's all
right you know the first four is pretty
tough to pick
did you play hoops growing up yeah
absolutely i played in high school
played um
yeah and i love it i just i just and
i played until a year ago when i got my
hip replacement we played noontime
basketball here every day
well what's the scouting report on you
point guard commissioner of the league
pick the best players to be on my team
call the fouls
and we do pretty well
[Laughter]
are you like the uh the globetrotters
and the opponents the washington
generals
you guys never lose it's kind of that
way
so we appreciate the competition now
whenever we get some
have you been to the masters
i have been one time and i'm actually
going
saturday night to spend a little time
there on sunday
now are you gonna be the guest of uh
somebody who's playing or
just as a spectator
you know i'm i'm doing uh some function
there
okay uh for somebody on saturday night
so i'm just going to stay over my
daughter
and her husband want to go they've never
been to the masters
so typically when i do things like that
i
go and come back but this time they
wanted to go so we're going to stay
and they're going to have an opportunity
to watch on sunday i took my son when i
was a coach at lsu when he was probably
maybe 14 years old or something um but
that's the only time i've actually gone
to watch it
have you played it but oh yeah i play
every year
you know every year i go um there are
several
you know supporters of the program here
that our members there and they
you know one of the three or four of
them invite me every year and
you know we um we you know i enjoy it i
enjoy
i that's probably one of my favorite
things to do
do you listen to your caddy
uh yeah absolutely i don't think you can
play there if you don't
i know not on the greens at least i mean
it's ridiculous
i try to tell people that whatever you
see on tv it is nothing like that in
person
because it there are so many mounds and
the undulated undulation of the green
like it's crazy
and and i had a caddy tell me hey don't
ask any questions i'm going to tell you
where to put it and you putt it right
there and i
listen to him and probably save ten
shots
no question if you didn't have somebody
telling you
i mean i can't figure it out i mean
maybe other people can figure it out and
i'm sure pro guys can figure it out but
man i tell you what there's elephants
buried in some of them
and it's it's ridiculous he's uh nick
saban
of all the places that that you know you
play golf
i mean to me that's the one place
you know i'm the kind of golfer that
just i'm happy to hit it on the green
but hitting on the green there in the
wrong place
is you might be better off hitting the
sand trap
uh he's nick saban the alabama head
coach uh what
is your role or was your role at a pro
day
um really not much of anything
um you know i get asked questions
by a few guys mostly that i know which
is quite a few
guys in the nfl i know that i work with
when i was in the nfl
and you know watch the players encourage
them
um usually do a little something for the
media
but it's um very minimal
um root for the players hope they do
well
try to encourage them uh to do the right
things
relative to now i was on the other side
being a pro coach for eight years so i
really try to encourage our guys to know
that you know working for them
cooperating with them
these are things that create value for
you now refusing to do anything
doesn't create value for you so you know
i i just
i always tell guys you don't want to
give anybody the reason to say but
you know i used to listen for that word
all the time in a draft report and as
soon as it came up
nothing good ever came after it and i i
said so
the choices and decisions you make don't
don't give anybody a reason to say but
they're looking for reasons
not to pick you right they're trying to
find is there any flaws is there
something wrong with you
but don't don't give them any reasons
for that and you got to cooperate
to be able to do that what did you tell
kyle shanahan about mac jones
he didn't ask me a thing didn't ask me a
thing i said hi to him
uh john lynch too they did not ask me a
thing about them
they didn't ask me a thing wow maybe
they thought they weren't allowed to
because
you know out there on in the pro day
floor which is where i saw them
yeah you know i i think that they they i
don't know all their rules but i think
their wizards are not really allowed
to talk to me um so
you know i stood by belichick we didn't
talk but
um so it you know i don't know what
their rules are and i don't know what
the reason for some of the rules are but
there's where it is wait so you stand
next to belichick but you guys don't
talk and you guys are great friends
yeah well we talked a little bit before
you know
i mean whether by phone or whatever
we we we always talk about whatever we
need to talk about
here hey linda was his secretary in
cleveland my secretary now or
my assistant and uh so he always comes
up and says hello to her
you know it's that's
kind of lifelong when did you know mac
jones was something
different considering we thought he was
going to kentucky he was a three-star
recruit you had two of there but
was there a moment where you go there's
something
different here because it feels like the
nfl on these scouts
kind of stumbled upon him the last
couple of weeks here
well i i think that a lot of people got
interested
by the way he played last year um
i mean he did a phenomenal job i mean we
had really good players around them no
doubt a couple really good receivers
you know good couple good run backs
really good offensive line
but max really intelligent very smart
very accurate with the ball
and makes good decisions about where he
chose the ball so that's a really good
starting point for a guy being a good
quarterback you know you can go on
all these measurables and arm strength
and all that but that really doesn't
make you a good quarterback and
you know guys like aaron rodgers who i
was at miami when aaron rodgers came out
and you know his coach told me that's
how he was
and in a workout he was probably not
that much more impressive than
you know somebody else but those
instinctive intangibles that
that a quarterback has or you know
invaluable to being successful at the
position
and i think that's why that's so hard to
evaluate
and um and i think that's why that's the
number one failure position
in the draft is because of that being
such a hard thing to evaluate
so but you asked me a question about
when that i met comeback jones was going
to be a good player
i was impressed with the way mack played
in fall camp
and i was hopeful that he would be able
to continue to be able to play that way
you know when the games came and you
know he didn't disappoint
you know at all he really prepared for
the games well
he sort of changed his mindset you know
early in his career he was a
an anxious guy that you know really had
a tough time overcoming
you know mistakes in his own mind and
playing the next play
and you know he kind of you know got
over that
matured through that and um
you know he really prepared well for
games and he was always able to execute
exactly what we wanted to do so
i think the world of them and you know
we've had a lot of three-star
players you know everybody goes on these
stars but um
you know quentin williams didn't have a
lot of stars and he was the third guy
picked in the draft and
josh jacobs didn't have a lot of stars
and he was you know a first-round draft
pick so
but we don't go on the stars i never
know how many stars a guy has
until like after recruiting you know
somebody says hey you had
this many nine star guys or five star
guys or whatever they are
you know and um i i just
we evaluate kind of like you do for the
draft
and we have criteria for what we're
looking for in every position
and it's very similar to what a lot of
pro teams would look for at those
positions
that's how we try to develop our team
and develop our players and
when we find guys we don't care how many
stars they have
and just you know kind of try to develop
those guys and some of them have turned
out to be pretty good and some of the
guys that had a lot of stars
you know turned out to not be so good
before i let you go was it uh
true that mack was carving up the
defense in practice
and you told him to kind of settle down
and stop
carving up the defense did that actually
happen
well i remember the causing of the
defense part that happened quite often
i don't ever remember asking them to
quit doing that
uh he might have felt that because it
was a little frustrating at times trying
to develop
you know we had like eight new starters
on defense and they didn't have a lot of
confidence so
you know when you go out there every day
and get sort of
you know shredded it's kind of hard to
develop confidence but
in that group but i i knew we were going
to have the kind of team that
was going to have to outscore people
especially early on
until we got the defense a little better
and they got a little better the
you know second half of the year and um
you know the offense was very productive
and that's how we won
uh recapping uh one of the greatest wins
of your career
baylor wins the national championship
you win your bracket
so uh pretty pretty good year for you
coach and uh always great to catch up
with you
yeah but i didn't want anything except
bragging rights for the i don't want
anybody to think out there i'm a gambler
because i'm not
but that's that's when it comes to your
family
to to be able to have bragging rights
it's it's worth a lot more than the
money oh you got bragging rights coach i
would have everybody in your family run
a lap
yeah well i just like to talk
[Laughter]
and i i told everybody last night to say
look i'm going to show class
in this video i called my daughter with
like four minutes to go in the game and
i said you know i'm not ready to claim
victory i just want to know if you're
ready to conceive
she had gonzaga she wasn't too happy
about that
that's good uh great great to catch up
with you safe
travels to augusta there coach and uh
we'll connect with you
uh some sometime down the road all right
buddy thanks dan appreciate you have a
good day
that's coach saban